have you I always find that I need to
eat during the night what's a good
balanced snack that I can make before
bed let me show you all my favorite
hunger crushing combo bedtime snacks
we're
bedtime snack
got our oats we got some hemp hearts
some milk whatever you got on hand pinch
of salt give it a quick stir and I'm
popping this into my microwave for a few
minutes I love to add in a little bit of
ripe banana and just kind of mash that
right in there for some extra carbs a
spoonful of almond butter because
almonds are a great source of natural
melatonin for the body and sour cherries
are also known for their sleep promoting
benefits and of course you guys know I
love a little protein before bed because
that is the key to helping you stay
Fuller all night long so this is the
Cherry Barcia from Bill Barr it's got 17
grams of protein and it also packs the
same kind of cherry flavor that we love
let some of that chocolate just kind of
like melt in and I promise you you will
not be hungry at midnight